a kid who was on tick tock with his
mother and said that his mother
is going to make him join the lgbtq
community
does your mom say you have to be lgbt
i'm not no i think she's what i want to
be but something fun
go ahead let's fight keep talking stay
with yourself
my mom doesn't matter if i'm up if i am
gay or a lesbian or any of that she
doesn't care all she cares about is that
i'm a part of it
and if i'm not a part of it she'll try
to convince me to i'm going to join it
because i
what are you saying right now
facts that i would convince you to join
what the eligibility plus
this is bad
obviously we're blurring the kids faces
unlike this abusive mother who's putting
her kids on the internet for her own
edification and pleasure and gain
but you can see when the kid starts to
answer this question the other kid looks
at the mother
and says and the other kid he puts his
hand he says don't maybe you don't
answer that the kid says no it's okay
it's just my mom she doesn't care if i'm
a lesbian or gay or transgender or
whatever she just wants me to be one of
them i've just got to be part of it i've
just got to be in some way part of the
lgbt community and then the mother says
huh wait hold on she realizes this
answer's not going the way she wanted it
to
when she put her kids on screen
and she she says what are you talking
about what are you saying he says facts
obviously you want me to do that and so
this was put out by libs of tick tock
which is now reporting
that the mother is apparently quite
involved in the lgbtq community and has
some kind of romantic relationship with
some kind of transgender type so she's
obviously promoting this sort of stuff
if you've been in the store recently any
store you'll notice that the cost of
everything is going through the roof
i've noticed this especially when i go
to the grocery store or the drugstore
and i want to buy
cleaning supplies well
we have a solution for you and it's a
really phenomenal solution our partner
naturally it's clean
naturally it's clean is the best
cleaning
supply i have ever used i love it it's
amazing their secret is plant-based
enzymes so it's natural it's not gonna
you know fill your house with toxins or
anything like that it's natural
it's totally safe
it's good for kids it's good for pets
but it's really going to work it's going
to get your home really really clean
whether it's carpet whether that's for
countertops whatever and it's going to
really help save you a lot of time and
money not only because they've got these
great cleaning supplies at a very fair
price but because they will use
concentrates so one bottle of their
concentrate can can give you up to 12
bottles of cleaning supplies it's really
good for the environment it's really
good for your
pocketbook and it's really really good
to help clean your home try them right
now
my listeners can get their hands on the
naturally it's clean daily wire
essential kit
that is stocked with four great products
for fifteen percent off visit
naturallyitsclean.com
michael mich ael use promo code michael
mich ael to save an additional 15 off
your order do not delay
a break from bite inflation is here
try out these incredible cleaning
products in your home today by visiting
naturallyitsclean.com
michael mich ael for more information
people are shocked
that the kid would say this people are
shocked that a mother would do of course
i'm not shocked at all
being in the lgbt
lmnop community carries social currency
i know that the
liberal establishment pretends
that to be in the lgbt lmnop comes with
lots of sacrifice and and terrible
burdens and that it's you're actually a
persecuted minority but that's not the
case
every
power center in this country
promotes
lgbtq if you
disparage lgbtq
even the crazy even the even the tea
which is the craziest part of all
if you
disparage that you will be censored
often you will be de-platformed often
you could face professional
repercussions you could be fired you
could be kicked out of school
depending on exactly how you do it you
might face some criminal penalties
you can't do that you're not allowed
it's one of the most protected groups in
the country
actually
the only group that you are allowed to
discriminate against legally the only
group
sexual group that you're allowed to
and encouraged to publicly insult and
attack is what it's
straight people
that's it it's the opposite of what the
libs are telling us
on race on sex on religion on the entire
political order all of the powerful
institutions are telling you
this group is really persecuted
and this group is doing the persecuting
and so
well what's the effect of that the
effect of that is when all of the power
centers are smearing one group and are
lauding another group and
protecting another group and
giving advantage to another group then
then the groups are actually flipped
then the one that we're told is
persecuted is not it's powerful and the
one that we're told is powerful is
actually
persecuted that's the way these things
work i'm so glad you like that clip stop
before you go anywhere
ring that bell please
i'd appreciate that you'll get the
notifications you'll find all the
wonderful videos that we put out
and if our friends here at youtube don't
send you those notifications head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts for free you subscribe to
the michael knowles show you will get
the entire show uncensored too hot for
social media
check it out see you next time
[Music]